(light music)
- [Narrator] If you're having trouble
finding Mr. or Mrs. Swipe
Right, it might be time
to turn to matchmaking's
ancient roots, literally.
Because deep in a forest in Germany stands
a 600 year-old oak tree
that has introduced hundreds
of single people.
(light music)
(bell dings)
(light piano music)
(dreamy music)
It all began around 1890 when
the forest ranger's daughter
met a chocolate maker from Leipzig.
The father did not approve
of their relationship.
(dreamy music)
They had to find a way
to exchange messages,
so they used a tree about 300 feet away
from the forest ranger's office.
A branch had broken off, forming a hole,
and it was there they put their letters.
(girl laughs)
(owl hoots)
Once her father learned
how they were secretly
communicating, he finally
approved of their relationship.
They married under the
tree on June 2nd, 1891,
after which the tree became
known as Bridegroom's Oak.
(Karl speaks in foreign language)
And people still send letters
to the tree to this day.
But can you truly find a life partner
for the price of postage?
No one knows better than Karl-Heinz.
(Karl speaks in foreign language)
But there was one letter
that caught his eye.
(Karl speaks in foreign language)
(dreamy music)